you know I heard Dax Shepard was
actually supposed to direct this movie
sky wire is this petition Shepards
hitches and our jeast so I put her to
poll because two trailers dropped at the
same time one for Tom Hanks's Greyhound
and this one's Scoob final trailer and
our community page 80% of people voted
that we should cover the Scoob final
trailer over the Greyhound trailer that
is democracy and that's like that's like
some candidates and results in the
recent Super Tuesday let's watch this
they were tasty Kobe was
wait who is that voice Robert that's
Wahlberg
sounds like Wahlberg sound like Ryan
Reynolds is Mark Wahlberg I caught his
name ah
alright that's looks like there's a lot
more people involved in the Scooby Doo
and the gangs origin tale easily my
favorite joke was the one with Velma
Daphne and Fred because when that joke
started I was like finally really really
hit home for me I love a joke that's
like aha funny comedy judge over here
I love the animation honestly I don't
have nostalgia for scooby-doo I know you
do I know a lot of people do Scooby Doo
- it was always on cable which I didn't
have
poor me but for what we're getting I
mean I don't know if this will like
leave an impact on me but it looks cute
it looks charming it looks passable it
looks funny Mark Wahlberg is funny
everything that we've got I know we had
a lot of thoughts in the last trailer I
don't know if you have any like brand
new thoughts that are completely
different
all those adjectives you just dropped
are kind of how this feels to me like
will be probably amusing hit or miss
comedy and pretty cute overall I mean
this I don't think is really for me
necessarily I don't know I was kind of
lukewarm on this particular trailer just
because it kind of is awash in pop music
and stuff like that this feels like it's
selling me three movies at the same time
because I feel like you got the young
Scooby and Shaggy story and then you got
Scooby and Shaggy on this
ship sorry and then you've gotten the
mystery ink gang dealing with Dick
Dastardly so it's like you've got all
these things and I can't tell exactly
which one of them it's playing the most
- I think it's playing more to the
sci-fi stuff I feel like that Scooby
origin stuff is gonna be narrated over
and pretty quick feel like those be a
few minutes you know you got some like
spooky sequences here look like they
take place around Halloween perhaps I
don't know but I feel like it's leaning
heavily more into its sci-fi elements
yeah which is just a different flavor
for me I'd have to see it and get used
to it I mean to me it kind of smacks a
little bit of superheroes are in and big
sci-fi action is in how do we revitalize
scooby-doo right now because that's a
properties that's kind of how this feels
to me but then again maybe that's a
really good take and I should just open
my mind to sci-fi Scooby Doo because
there are comics and stuff that do that
so so are we hash tagging not my scoop
I'm not gonna go that because there are
elements of this that do look cute Will
Forte and scooby-doo you know he seems
like a decent shaggy you know it's a
trailer and I know that they put a lot
of the obvious jokes and stuff in the
trailers I'm kind of in the middle on
this but I'm also not the most nostalgic
for scooby-doo I just kind of grew up it
was around I liked it when I watched it
yeah all right Castle are you excited
for Scoob leave your thoughts down below
or do you want them to release the DAX
cut yeah I want our Titian we're gonna
put it up put it out Warner changed org
subscribe click that notification belt